- The reason that we're here today is we
are going to go on a learning walk
to look at different ways that some of our
teachers are using their flexible spaces.
We're looking to become
more of a facilitator.
- The power of the professional
development on campus
is that all of our staff
gets to learn from one another.
It's all about transforming
teaching and learning
and building a culture of
collaboration.
- At Kettle Moraine High School,
we place priorities on transforming our campus
and part of that is changing
what our space looks like
to allow teachers to move
from in front of the classroom
and allow students
to really own that learning.
- We've been working to
really personalize to different learners
and allow our students to choose
where they feel they'll learn best.
- Classrooms with more open space
instead of rows of desks...
it makes a lot easier to work with
other people.
- Over the last seven years
most of our spaces have changed
and we're right now changing over
the last few classrooms.
Our social studies department is going to be
getting their new furniture next year
and as part of their transition
we took them on a learning walk.
- So we're looking to continue
to empower students through
choice of where they're sitting, who
they're choosing to work with.
Kind of be looking for things that you maybe want
to replicate for your space.
- A learning walk is a way
for teachers to get out
and view other teachers
in their environment.
- Spread out as we get in.
- In my room, rather than having everyone
in the class reading the same book,
I've actually been able to put them
into different groups with furniture
that can be easily moved by students
and then they can lead
their own discussions
and they have a lot more
ownership in their learning.
- (Student) but she's like so focused
on like pleasing others
- (Student) I think that kind of makes her
unlikable to the reader a little bit.
- They were sharing out ideas.
A lot of what they were discussing
was very high-level critical thinking.
To share out in a large group
might have been very intimidating for them,
so the smaller groups worked really well.
- Not too long ago we went through
remodeling the library,
remodeling the cafeteria,
remodeling the common spaces,
to where the cafeteria itself
becomes a flexible space that,
minus lunch hour, you can
bring your classroom down there.
It's not just classrooms,
it's the entire campus
has become a flexible learning space.
- We have couches and
we have high-top tables,
we also have two small rooms
to allow for some privacy
yet still allow a teacher to supervise.
And then the last classroom we went to,
we saw the teacher allowing students
to make choices of whether
they were going to work alone or work together.
When a teacher doesn't have to be
in the front of the room,
they can make choices with their curriculum
that allow students
to choose a path to follow.
- Some of the teachers that went on the walk have
had the same classroom setup for
the last 20 years,
and to hear their ideas about
how they can use this
new furniture to enhance
the things they're already doing
was really exciting.
- Today when I was looking at
all the different classrooms
I wasn't as afraid as
I have been in the past
of having students facing
in the other direction.
- Students told me that when
instruction is being given
everyone sits and turns their chairs,
therefore is focusing on the teacher,
and then when it's time
to get to work then they pair off.
- We need creative spaces in order to
teach the best way that we can.
Students really work much better
and learn much better
when they can get up and move.
- The idea of flexible furniture is not just
to get something new and fancy
that might look good
as you walk past a classroom.
It's truly about how can we help students
have a better educational experience.
I'm very excited for
that possibility next year.